-We're going to take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
-Okay. Great.
-Okay?
One person asks the questions,
the other person has to answer
each question
as soon as it's asked.
I mean, immediately.
No thinking.
-Don't think. Okay.
-It doesn't matter
if the answer is right or wrong
or doesn't make any sense.
It just has to be the very first
thing that pops into your head.
-Blurt it out. Okay.
-Yes.
-Because you are our guest, I
will read your questions first.
-Okay, great.
-Are you ready?
-I'm normally not a person
who likes games,
but I like this game.
-Okay. Here we go. Think fast.
[ Clears throat ]
-Okay. Okay.
-What's the coolest thing to say
after you drink a beer?
-Spaghetti and meatballs!
-When you were a baby,
what was your first word?
-I want milk.
-Where do pancakes go?
-Zero playground.
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Laughter ]
-Spaghetti and meatballs. Yes.
That's exactly what I --
-I love it.
-That's the game.
-Okay, good, I love it.
-Think fast. Here we go.
Now you read me the questions,
and I think fast.
-You can't control it.
You just say whatever you want.
-Dude, already I'm telling you,
you already won.
-Okay. Ready, Jimmy? Here we go.
-Okay.
-What did you order
on Amazon last night?
-A blue elbow!
-What noise do penguins make?
-Erraagghgh!
-If you were a rapper,
what would your name be?
-Tasty G.
-What's your go-to pickup line?
-Hey, you want tickets
to see Tasty G?
[ Bell dinging ]
I know him pretty well.
-That's good. That's good.
-I know him pretty well.
-I love it.
-Tasty G.
That's not a person, right?
Is it a real --
That's not a rapper, is it?
-No.
-Yeah, I'm looking at him.
-Oh, thanks, buddy.
Appreciate it. Thanks.
All right, now this is
the final round, okay?
In this round,
we'll both pick up a card
with the same set
of questions, okay?
We're going to ask and answer
them one at a time
going back and forth.
-Okay. Great.
-Okay. I'll start.
-Ask and answer. Okay.
-Ready?
Here we go.
-Okay, good.
-Where's Maurice?
-At the temperature festival.
[ Laughter ]
That was good.
-Gosh. That's great.
-Okay, sorry. How do you
show someone that you care?
-You grab them by the ankles.
When is the --
When is the Super Bowl?
-Usually on Wednesday nights
after the penis gallery.
What do you say
after someone sneezes?
-Achoo.
How long is
a fisherman's minute?
-16 seconds, and that's it.
Okay, what's the best word
to say with an Irish accent?
-[ Irish accent ]
Shaddamahern!
[ Normal voice ] What's the name
of my new hit character?
-Jeremiah Playsville.
-That's exactly right!
There you have it!
That was "Think Fast"
with Molly Shannon.
Jeremiah Playsville.
"The Other Two"
premieres tomorrow night
at 10:30 p.m. on Comedy Central.